I can't believe they've managed to make
1 million flavors together and yet
somehow I can taste each individual one
it's remarkable
I got no flavor that's all I deserve
really oh look I I appreciate you trying
to cheer me up I really do but you don't
understand this was the very first
neighborhood that I got to design it was
my chance to prove myself and I've blown
it you know sometimes a floor make
something even more beautiful like what
Cindy Crawford now short Cheers
okay javi if I made one tiny mistake in
my design if there's a single glitch in
the system
if even one blade of grass is angled a
fraction of a degree off the whole
neighborhood is compromised whose dog is
that guys whose dog is that whose dog is
that see this is one of those glitches I
was talking about nice try update
whoo how does a close one
chica have you seen my dog magical trash
bags
[Music]
Janet I'm finished with cleanup and I'm
ready to fly how do I start
hop on the launchpad and conjure an
image that brings you pure joy some
people think of their wedding day or
favorite vacation spot people puking on
rollercoasters people puking on
rollercoasters
[Laughter]
Janet any chance this is a scheduled
trash storm so here's the situation
Aveda I kind of kicked your dog into the
Sun but I got her back
everything everything seems fine okay
everyone
it is merely a construct of a dog it
feels no pain or joy or love teacup
doesn't love me oh oh no no no it
definitely feels love do you actually
want a dog that loves you a little bit
more because I can kick her right back
into the Sun and get you another one
just like that no I'm making things
worse all right that's what I breathe
thank you freeze if you do don't just
breathe because everything's fine
Michael it's fine
before you say anything that's it I just
don't want you to say what mr. jerk
nothing it just started raining trash
out of nowhere for no reason at all okay
fine fine my bag broke and I ditched the
trash instead of taking it all the way
to the dumpster but in my defense there
were only five minutes left in flying
and I wanted so fine how is that a
defense you made a bad choice I made a
bad choice we could have literally been
flying and all you wanted to do is talk
about morals I mean you're like the
worst part of Superman this is a relief
I can stop my deliberations you are a
selfish person and it is pointless to
help you you are on your own how about
this trash storm gunner more cleaning up
to do so it's a dream come true I mean
even you have to admit Kaiser psycho
you